>> Tucker: IN OHIO, AN ABORTION
CLINIC IS ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
GET ABORTIONS ON THE GROUND THAT
IT'S A GOOD PARENTING DECISION.
THE CLINIC PRETERM HAS STARTED A
CAMPAIGN SAYING MY ABORTION, MY
LIFE.
THEY SET UP 16 BILLBOARDS AROUND
CLEVELAND AND EXTOLL THE TERM
THAT SAYING ABORTION IS RIGHT
AND IT'S A PARENTING DECISION.
U.C. SAN FRANCISCO PURPORTEDLY
SAID THAT THEY'RE CALLING ON TV
SHOWS TO HAVE MORE ABORTION
RELATED COMEDY TO NORMALIZE THE
PROCEDURE.
DOCTOR, YOU AGREE.
THANKS FOR COMING UP.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: SO ABORTION COMEDY.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY IS THE FUNNY
PART ABOUT ABORTION?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY'RE USING
IT AS A FUNNY THING.
THEY'RE USING IT TO BRING OUT --
TO MAKE IT MORE OF A REAL THING,
A MORE OF A -- I CAN'T HEAR.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU HEAR ME,
DOCTOR?
>> ONE SEC.
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE USING IT
AS A COMEDY.
I THINK THEY'RE TRYING TO
STIGMATIZE IT WITH WOMEN.
>> Tucker: AND I THINK THAT
SOUNDS PROBABLY RIGHT.
WHY DO YOU THINK THERE'S A
STIGMA AROUND ABORTION?
>> I THINK IN THE WORLD THERE'S
SO MUCH STIGMA AROUND IT.
IT'S A VERY HARD DECISION TO
MAKE FOR A WOMAN.
IT'S A NO-WIN SITUATION IF
YOU'RE PUT --
>> Tucker: WHY THE STIGMA?
>> WHY IS IT CONSIDERED A
STIGMA?
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> BECAUSE IT'S ENDING A LIFE
FOR SOME PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO IF YOU THINK -- BUT IF YOU
DON'T THINK IT'S ENDING A LIFE,
SHOULDN'T BE A STIGMA AT ALL,
RIGHT?
>> IT'S NOT ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER.
IT'S A TRAUMATIC THING THAT
ENDING A LIFE.
IN ANOTHER WAY, YOU'RE PUT IN A
NO-WIN SITUATION BECAUSE
CHOICE.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO WHY WOULD YOU -- ALL OF
THAT -- YOU'RE PROBABLY IN THE
MAINSTREAM OF VIEW ON THAT.
SO WHY THE IMPULSE TO MAKE LIGHT
OF IT OR DESTIGMATIZE IT IN
COMEDY OR PUT UP BILLBOARDS
ISN'T THAT MAKING LIGHT OF IT,
MINIMIZING IT?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S MAKING
LIGHT OF IT.
I THINK IT'S BRINGING OUT THE
ISSUE OF ABORTION, THAT IT'S AN
OPTION.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANYTHING
ABOUT ABORTION THAT MAKES YOU
PERSONALLY UNCOMFORTABLE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S A VERY HARD THING FOR WOMEN
TO GO THROUGH.
I THINK IT'S AN ABSOLUTE NO-WIN
SITUATION FOR WOMEN.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
"NO-WIN SITUATION".
>> IT MEANS A WOMAN WITH AN
UNWANTED PREGNANCY HAS TO MAKE A
DECISION.
THE DECISION IS A NO-WIN
SITUATION.
SHE HAS TO END THE LIFE OF AN
UNBORN BABY.
YOU KNOW, WE SHOULD CELEBRATE
IT, WE SHOULD CONVINCE OTHERS
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH IT,
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
I THINK IT'S A TRAUMATIC THING
THAT SOMETIMES THERE'S NO OTHER
OPTION.
THAT'S WHY I DO KEEP SAYING IT'S
A NO-WIN SITUATION BECAUSE IT
IS.
>> Tucker: BUT I NEVER HEAR -- I
GUESS I DISAGREE WITH YOUR LAST
POINT ABOUT THERE'S NO OTHER
PARENTHOOD LEADERS SAYING YOU
SHOULD WEAR A T-SHIRT ANNOUNCING
THERE'S A DOWN SIDE.
>> WELL, THAT'S THEIR OPINION.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR OTHER PEOPLE.
PERSONALLY I SEE SO MUCH TRAUMA
AROUND IT IN MY OFFICE AND --
IT'S A HARD DECISION.
ON THE OTHER HAPPENED, IT'S A
HARD DECISION TO KEEP A BABY
THAT A MOTHER DOESN'T -- CAN'T
TAKE CARE OF PSYCHOLOGICALLY OR
PHYSICALLY.
>> Tucker: NO, IT'S A TOUGH
SITUATION.
I THINK IT'S A FIRST STEP TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.